a separate issue facing the Trump
administration is a backlog of more than
700,000 security clearances one
investigator tells CBS News the White
House security process quote is the peak
of what the problem is throughout the
government Jeff Pegues is outside FBI
headquarters in Washington Jeff good
morning good morning yesterday the White
House blamed the FBI for delays in the
security clearance process but in a sign
of the strain between the bureau and the
White House the FBI responded saying
that it just conducts the background
checks it does not grant security
clearances so help me God nearly 13
months into the Trump administration
more than a dozen top officials are
working with an interim security
clearance
among them the president's son-in-law
Jared Kushner Rob Porter was on that
list until he resigned last week amid
allegations of domestic violence well to
me it suggests a breakdown in the
security clearance system Chris White or
is a former assistant director of the
FBI he says some officials in the
Clinton administration relied on interim
clearances but that it is unusual for so
many officials to not have full security
clearances at this point and to have
someone with an interim security
clearance for over a year seems very
excessive it sort of defeats the purpose
of having a security clearance process
in the first place
he says within FBI headquarters there is
a special unit called spin or special
enquiries it handles White House
security clearances which are designed
to be expedited in about 45 days once
the FBI completes its investigation its
findings are handed over to the White
House which has discretion in deciding
whether to approve a full security
clearance my real question was about how
he could be doing this job without a
security clearance Lisa Braun was a
staff secretary in President Obama's
White House you want to make sure that
they aren't working for a foreign
government that you want that they're
upright and honest person that they
aren't somehow going to be susceptible
to blackmail and that is why the
security clearance process is essential
for any White House CBS News has been
at the FBI wrapped up Rob Porter's
background check at least eight months
before his resignation Nora
wow that's interesting Jeff thank you so
much